I'd like to get an idea of your
background since we really do we're
biologists we're microbiologist and
biology based as anybody had have you
had biology in high school good all
right anybody had biology at the
university level good anybody had a
class and bioengineering or microbiology
you're a bioengineer chemical engineer
okay all right so then we don't
necessarily have to start from absolute
basics you probably know a lot of a lot
of the basic terminology that was one of
the things by the way that the cleantech
open drilled into us is that you really
have to use common terminology a lot of
people that you see in this business
especially venture capitalists really
have very little background in biology
and almost no background at all in
microbiology so we have done at helio
bios's is we have developed a process
for producing sugars at a very very low
cost and I think you realize that cost
is really what is hampering the biofuels
industry in the bio products industry
today so that's really what we have done
and let me just give you a little bit of
history here about myself I'm really a
microbial ecologist and I do a lot of
fieldwork and I look at environmental
systems and how they work together okay
and in addition to that I you know I've
had a lot of experience running a lab
I've had graduate students
undergraduates and and so I've run the
gambit there David and I first got
together many years ago on a project
developing a bioreactor and designing a
bioreactor for specific purposes for
NASA and although I'm going to stress in
my talk that we don't do anything with
genetic modified genetically modified
organisms I'm not against using
genetically modified organisms and
circumstances in fact I was a founding
member of NASA synthetic biology program
so David if you can take over I've got
it I've got a microphone here too so
good afternoon everybody and I also it
got my PhD here at Stanford many years
ago and I don't recognize the campus
anymore so that's why we got a little
lost coming over here it's changed a lot
but at any rate I focus on plant
physiological ecology looking at the
interaction between organisms in the
environment and coupling biological and
engineered systems and did that at NASA
Ames when rock and i were there looking
at control deck illogical life-support
systems I've also spent a lot of time
doing a geological restoration here
locally around in Palo Alto
community-based stewardship using my
ecology to help you know protect our
natural areas which is you know
something there's a passion of mine as
rocca mentioned we've done a lot of
design and development and operation of
the bioreactor work with plant grow
systems and also we originally started
with this mouse and algal system looking
at gas exchange so a lot of coupling
biology and engineering together for you
know for long duration space missions
but for now in Hilo boss is looking at
industrial applications of how you have
you put biology and technology and
engineering and industrial processes
together make them all work so looking
at the mass and energy balance of those
and then I've also done quite a bit of
government service around here locally
so I'm going to hand it back to Rocco to
tell a little bit the story about that
you know what our company does and how
it actually got founded in some of the
original ideas well way back in 2005 I
had an idea that said well you know
because biofuels were coming into play
then and everybody was really interested
in biofuels and an ethanol production
and one of the ideas I had is let's just
see if we can take the sun's energy and
turn that into ethanol not quite
directly but almost and the idea I had
which someone else came up with you know
at the same time basically was to use
organisms called cyanobacteria okay and
that's what we still use so I Anna
bacteria used to be called blue-green
algae but they're not algae they are
bacteria and I said okay let's see if we
can genetically modify a cyanobacterium
to produce
ethanol and we did we were successful
but there were many stumbling blocks one
of them was we got it to do so
efficiently that it killed itself second
one was okay well let's let's see if we
can modify it and control it well
there's many things you can do with
molecular biology and we did it and so
we could control it we actually could
control the production of ethanol and
they said okay now we can do it and it's
not going to kill itself but our
productivity decreased the next step was
to see whether or not we could actually
start doing it in larger larger than a
test tube go to a flask and when we do
that we saw that we were using losing a
lot of our product through evaporation
so finally I said this is just this is
just getting too much you know and we're
doing too many things too many things we
have to do it's not going to be
efficient never and I don't know if any
of you follow the biofuels industry at
all but you know I said that that there
was someone else doing it essentially
simultaneously well they didn't give up
it's a company called algun hall and
what algun all did has essentially took
Santa bacteria and they put the same
genes in it that we did and they
produced ethanol however I kept track of
the company by the way they are still
not doing well at all they're not
commercial not on a commercial scale at
all because they had exactly the same
problems we have and what they've done
to act to try to have eliminate the
evaporation as they now have little
ponds and they put a tent over it and
they have the ethanol condense onto this
tent and still that seems to me not like
I still think I made the right decision
in abandoning that idea they would
disagree so that's how it all began and
that's how we started with cyanobacteria
and for that project we needed sign a
bacteria that would grow very
efficiently but then and we found them
so we had a bunch of isolates okay come
on there we go
and we started off believe it or not at
a place called the SETI Institute in
Mountain View California now many of you
probably have heard of the SETI
Institute and the way it got founded was
it was the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence well there's another part
of it that is astrobiology and I do a
lot of astrobiology and then but this
was an idea we had a separate from
astrobiology separate from the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence so we
got started at the SETI Institute and
that's what we did a lot of our
development work and that's how we we
essentially did a lot of the lab work to
come up with our consortium try to come
up with our consortium which is a group
or a mixed community of cyanobacteria
and we specifically chose marine
cyanobacteria rather than freshwater
cyanobacteria most of biofuel companies
use fresh water we use green we use
marine because marine organisms
especially cyanobacteria normally and
naturally make sugar but unlike
freshwater bacteria they excrete it
outside the cell so you don't have to
break the cell open and you don't have
to extract it so so we then started to
characterize put together our specific
consortium and we scaled okay this is
what a lot of people VC people you know
they don't think very much of we
considered it we scaled from test tubes
to 150 liters in an open culture system
outside this 150 litre open culture
system happened to be in aquarium so we
thought that was big it is a big deal
actually let's see here we go then we
have we decided we had to figure out how
we were actually going to go outside of
a laboratory and actually get something
done and could we do it we incorporated
ourselves back in 2010 formed a company
we're a c-corp from Delaware and so we
decided we would we needed partners and
one of the partners that we needed and
was willing to partner with us was s RI
international in menlo park and they
have an excellent facility for
conducting chemical and biological
analyses
then we said we need somebody who has
some expertise in pond building and pawn
and cultivating organisms in ponds so we
reached out to other companies Helia
being one of them who has that ability
because we're basically researchers and
when it comes to construction and
engineering that's not us and we realize
that fortunately and most recently we
also have formed more partnerships
because as a small company you can't
really do much yourself so not only with
sr i-- international but we also
partnered with Lawrence Berkeley
National Labs the a bpdu unit and Moss
Landing Marine Lab which is part of the
cal state system and a fish farming
company called monterey blue farm
monterey blue water farms there an
aquaculture company in monterey and we
got together and we wrote a proposal to
the doee because we are at a very early
stage even yet even though we've been
working on it for a long time we're at a
very early stage and you can't really
get bench or capitalists to invest in
you when you're this early they want
more of a sure thing so the government
hopefully we'll see their way clear this
fiscal year to give us some funding so
the idea here is to do all of that and
eventually build partnerships because
that's what it's going to take for
commercialization so our company really
we have to do all along the way chemical
and biological analyses and we have s RI
international and Lawrence Berkeley
National Labs to do that we also have to
scale up now from 150 liters to millions
and millions of gallons billions of
gallons but the first stage is to go to
thousands of gallons and that's what
we're going to do with moss landing
Marine Lab and go to a one acre type
facility with monterey blue water farms
and David will expand upon that later on
and then of course one of the biggest
problems you know that we have is
harvesting that sugar okay I said
you have a marine system it is so that
and we don't have to extract it that's
good but in a marine system that means
you have seawater so what do we have we
have salty sugar water even when we take
the organisms out how now what's the
next step well you have to separate the
salt from the sugars and so we are and
that's an engineering problem so we're
working with a couple of companies Nova
sep and Dow being among them to actually
develop a system to it's probably going
to be based on micro filtration to
dettol separate our sugars it's not you
know our particular sugar water solution
is is is a little bit different but this
kind of technology of separating sugar
and water especially at a company called
Nova sep they seem to do that regularly
so when we call them up and said can you
do this they said yes we just have to
design a system that's more fit for you
so it's almost off-the-shelf technology
and then last but not least when we do
this how much how much is it going to
cost us to produce this stuff and how
much can we sell it for and are we going
to be competitive and to be able to do
that and figure out which part of each
of us each of the systems that we have
costs and how we can tweak it we need a
techno-economic analysis and in fact
we've started that already with the NREL
has and today it's going to talk a
little bit more about this NL has a
special a special thing called end cap
that they will allow small companies 40
hours of time and they will develop a
model for your system and we have David
we'll cover that later we're also s RI
is going to expand upon that as well as
Lawrence Berkeley National Labs we've
also developed a somewhat of a
partnership with something called
lifecycle associates so one of the
questions that came up was a comparison
of energy density dues to we don't have
a pointer do we that's okay all right so
this is one of the things that I like
just quickly found and put up here and
if you look at natural gas it has an
energy density of a little over 40 mega
joules per kilogram
if you look at wood that has under 10
and ethanol is a little above 40 and you
look at crude oil we're approaching 40
maybe I think it's 42 oh thank you now
figure out exactly how to use this oh
now if we look here if you look at we
say we make sugars and we do make sugars
so where would sugars lie on their
sugars are about 17 to 20 okay that's
not as good as natural gas or diesel or
coke crude oil but it's not bad either
if you look at proteins and other
biomass they tend to be a little bit
higher but not much higher so we're all
I mean it we're all talking about
basically within the same order of
magnitude here the other thing you have
to consider here is that when you're
talking about crude oil crude oil as you
know as you know time temperature
pressure all of that stuff crude oil is
has a big advantage in that they have
they meaning the industry has about a
hundred years or more worth of
infrastructure to actually handle that
and to come in as a small upstart
biofuel or whatever you get you can get
intimidated easily well I wouldn't say
intimidated but it's a big behemoth I do
recall that one of our first
presentations was at a company called
Chevron we went to world headquarters
which is right over here in Richmond and
when we sat down and talked started our
presentation and talking about it
ethanol ethanol possible ethanol
production and our sugar and it really
realized there that they use billions
and billions and billions of gallons
even ten percent one of the things that
they said is we don't necessarily think
that you can run can make enough to make
it worthwhile correct because it just
overwhelms you one of the things they
have there is you can spot their tankers
as they come across the ocean and
they're just a line you know it's it's
amazing it well it was to me maybe not
to you since your engineers but it
was amazing to me that you can just see
the tankers are just lined up coming
across the ocean so you have to
appreciate the volumes that you're
trying to deal with here now if we look
at this energy density here we have to
make an awful lot of sugars to actually
meet the crude oil about you know crude
oil I said about 17 and crude oil is
actually I think about 42 just to put
things in perspective here now sign a
bacteria these are our guys then we put
several of them together in a mixed
community they are a very old lineage
they are bacteria they're not algae as I
said before and in fact three domains of
life bacteria archaea and you carry a
fair part of the bacteria they are the
first oxygen producing organisms that
evolved they essentially gave us our
oxygen atmosphere ah various they're
found everywhere you find them in in
lakes you find freshwater lakes salt
water salt water lakes actually you can
find cyanobacteria insult crusts you can
find them in deserts you can find them
living inside sandstone you can find
them on top of rocks when I say they
live everywhere they live everywhere
they are also Hardy that means and
they're well adapted to living in
variety of environments obviously and
the big thing that we found in that we
like is that the marine type organisms
excrete two sugars outside the cell the
other thing about them why we chose them
to work with is they happen to have the
highest photosynthetic efficiency of all
photosynthetic organisms that means that
they are very efficient at capturing
photons and changing those photons into
sugar or biomass approaching very
efficient now this may look a little
busy and it is but I'm only going to use
part of it but what I want to want you
to appreciate here is if you look on the
at the bottom here you'll see that this
is a timeline in billions of years this
gives the jerky and protozoa
i canna phanerozoic you know that the
what they called a different time
periods and this is actually taken out
of last week's science magazine and so
if we look here at the cyanobacteria
there the origin of cyanobacteria is
thought to have occurred about three and
a half billion years ago so they're
pretty ancient lineage and they're an
extraordinarily important lineage
because they did give rise to the oxygen
on the invite on the earth and here if
we look at the oxygen levels of the
atmosphere as a percent of the present
day atmospheric level we're a hundred
percent is where we are today okay
originally the earth was anaerobic it
was zero but then cyanobacteria evolved
and the sign of bacteria eventually
evolved a very efficient mechanism for
making energy and that was
photosynthesis and the most energetic
that most energy you can get is actually
using oxygen so they develop toxigenic
photosynthesis early on simultaneously
by the way since oxygen is really very
very toxic they had to evolve a
mechanism to detoxify the byproducts and
so they did that so it took them a while
to evolve the whole system and they
lived in microhabitats or micro
environments and so if you look at the
rise this is the this line here is
actually the rise of oxygen through time
and so the other thing not only did they
we're making oxygen and getting a lot of
energy out of themselves when they made
the oxygen and it's so energetic that
other organisms around sort of sniffing
around and got the oxygen as well and
then they started to utilize oxygen
because you can make so much energy out
of it and so eventually what happened as
the oxygen level rose on the earth due
to these cyanobacteria you see the
eventual evolution of eukaryotes those
are the bigger cells that have a cell
nucleus and then it really starts to
rise and right up here with this at this
time period you see that there's a lot
of oxygen in the atmosphere we're nearly
at where we are today and that
simultaneously coincides with the
evolution of and what's in a real big
bird
in diversity of life on earth and there
you got multicellularity the rise of
animals and plants and everything that
we see today and it's all due to these
guys here the cyanobacteria that's why I
think they're really quite amazing and
important and how do you know by the way
how does one actually try to figure out
what the oxygen level is three billion
years ago well one of the ways in you
can read the paper it's in last week's
science is they look at the isotopes of
chromium and they look at the oxidation
state of the isotopes of chromium and
other things and you can see that it's
very very low not oxidized and then it
spikes and becomes much more oxidized
now cyanobacteria are also important
because not only were their first photo
synthesizers but they are also the same
organisms that cause photosynthesis in
plants today they're responsible solely
for all oxygen aquila synthesis in some
way or another because there's a process
called endosymbiosis and what happened
was the eukaryotes essentially those
bigger organisms ate the little bacteria
but instead of just eating them
completely and digesting them eventually
what happened is the photosynthetic
apparatus in the cyanobacterium survived
inside the cell essentially became much
more simplified became part of the cell
and it gave rise to the what we call
chloroplasts today so chloroplasts
actually are silent or ancient remnants
of ancient cyanobacteria and then the
early the early first organisms here
eukaryotic organisms eventually gave
rise to the green algae which gave rise
to the land plants also gave rise to the
red algae and protists and other
photosynthetic organisms by the way we
talked about oxygen akoto synthesis but
because i am a microbiologist i want to
throw out there that there is an aerobic
non oxygen akoto synthesis they don't
use water that's the other thing I want
to make sure everybody knows as a
general thing to know is that oxygen eek
photosynthesis the oxygen comes from
water not from carbon dioxide
so these organisms by the way they get
their carbon from carbon dioxide but
it's not part of the photosynthetic
system okay so let's just look at
cyanobacteria versus algae a little bit
okay they are prokaryotes that means
that they do not have a cell a nuclear a
nucleus cell brown cell bow
membrane-bound nucleus excuse me they
are bacteria they are small they can
range from about a half a micron to two
microns some of them can be filaments
and they grow a nice long slimy strings
they use photosynthesis to get their
energy they get their carbon from carbon
dioxide in the air and some of them
actually get their nitrogen from
nitrogen in the air bacteria a lot of
not a lot but some bacteria actually
don't don't need fertilization or
anything they can just get two nitrogen
out of the air it's a very energetically
expensive process they are green because
of the chlorophyll they live as I said
essentially any anywhere or everywhere
you can find them not the same organism
but the sign of bacteria in general they
are vegetative and they go through
binary fission now if you look at algae
for example algae are eukaryotic they're
important in the biofuels industry they
are not plants a lot of people think
they're plants they're not they're
chlorophyta they gave rise to the higher
plants but they're not they are
eukaryotic they're not plants there tend
to be bigger there about 10 microns or
more they can be unicellular and they
can be multicellular they also get their
energy from photosynthesis they also fix
co2 that means they get to carbon from
from the air but they don't fix nitrogen
so they have to be fertilized they're
green because they use chlorophyll for
photosynthesis they live in water and
they can reproduce either vegetatively
or sexually so now if we look at our
system and algae especially centering
upon the bio
fuels industry here what you can see is
that I we use a mixed population of
genetically modified organisms most
algae that are used for biofuel use a
pure culture and a lot of them are
genetically modified to be much more
efficient we are counting on using some
type of managed open sea water small
acre pond minimum we managed they have
trouble they meaning excuse me mmm the
industry has tried to cultivate algae
and open water systems they use fresh
water systems primarily and they they
found that has been very difficult so a
lot of the companies such as Solazyme
has has gone to bioreactors
non-photosynthetic systems even though
they are using algae algae require
fertilization and the feedstock such as
the lipid or fats or whatever they're
trying to make are usually inside the
cell so the process has to go through a
dewatering process and then you have to
extract it we don't have to do any of
that products there are usually lipids
or rolls we make sugars primarily and
the end product errors for fuels and
nutraceuticals and ours two or four
fuels pharmaceuticals nutraceuticals and
bio plastics and with that I will turn
it over to David thanks Rocco so um they
can tell Rocco is real enthusiastic
about sign of bacteria and so when I
first got involved in this you know it's
it's a very interesting group of
organisms and we really tried to pick
features of that organism that would
overcome some of the hurdles that we see
in the biofuels industry and one of
those is the yield and the productivity
the land area that you use things like
that and so there's there's a concept
called biomimicry and you've probably
heard of that you know it's like
Leonardo da Vinci modeling his you know
flying machine based on bats right the
flying bats or people have used
biomimicry the the pads of tree frogs to
design better tread for tires
for example so you're in bio memory
you're taking a feature of an organism
an element of an organism and you're
using that to solve a complex human
problem or to solve an industrial
application for example velcro comes
directly out of the burrs and seeds of
some certain kinds of plants that people
looked at that microscopically and then
designed velcro from that so very useful
concept and so extending that a little
further become beyond an individual
organism or an individual feature of one
organism is a concept of eco mimicry and
that's a broader concept to look at you
know features of the natural world
ecosystems or in our case we're looking
at groupings of organisms we're putting
together groups of sign of bacteria
together so that they're more robust
they're more resilient as a community
single organisms just like a monoculture
and in farming right doesn't do as well
as if you have multi cropping so that
there are our concept here is to put
those organisms to get the nitrogen
fixation the ones that are good at
fixing nitrogen or not the ones
excreting the sugar but they're
internally getting this this mass and
energy flow going within this this
community of organisms that is
increasing the productivity of that
system increasing the resilience of it
to predation contamination things like
that so trying to use this concept both
in terms of the organisms and the
ecology of those organisms how we can
take that community structure and
translate it to an industrial
application but also how do we how do we
use eco members of concept to build an
integrated tightly coupled mass and
energy balance industrial system that is
actually producing biofuels Bio Products
food its energy and water efficient land
area efficient so trying to bring all
those things together along with
engineering I mean engineering is an
important part of all this because it's
not just the biology that we have to get
right to make the economics work we have
to get the engineering right as well so
just wanted to introduce those concepts
as something that is a company that
we've been relying on now just to sort
of drive the technology home a little
bit more we're talking about open salt
water ponds and you've seen you know
open algae ponds and things like that
something very similar to that and our
basic input materials sunlight sea water
and air right so we have very low cost
reliable a bun
it raw material inputs for our process
going into this consortium side of
bacteria and getting sugars out of that
and these would be land-based ponds this
lie it's a little bit miss you know
we're not we're not trying to do this in
the open ocean these would be land-based
ponds of course near the ocean where
you're not coming sea water and putting
that together now to look at in a little
more schematically here so here's our
inputs coming in the group of organisms
that's an actual photomicrographs with
some of the organisms in our consortium
and the products are coming out over
these fermentable sugars now these are
monosaccharides polysaccharides so
things like glucose fructose things like
that but also longer chain you know
larger molecular weight sugars that
might be you know directly convertible
into bio plastics or that you might
break those longer change sugars down
into the fermentable sugars that things
like yeast in e.coli would use to
process so that gives us this feedstock
supply and then that biomass conversion
is how we're trying to convert these
into useful products so this
artificially assembled consortium of
Santa bacteria we're projecting a yield
about a hundred tons of sugar per acre
per year and I'll look at that a little
bit more because that's sort of a key
laboratory finding that you know gives
allows us to compare ourselves to things
like LG LG oil to lignocellulosic
sources to corn to cane and things like
that ok so you know we've talked a
little bit about how these sugars and
what they go into so this is just more
of a schematic diagram of directly
processing them polysaccharides into
polymers and things like that and the
gold is if you imagine a barrel of oil
you know to be able to to compete with
oil to be able to sequester and leave
fossil fuels in the ground which is the
best way to combat climate change right
is to not take it out of the ground in
the first place you've got to replace
that barrel of oil well barrel of oil is
not just gasoline right gasoline is kind
of the waste product of taking all the
good stuff out of the barrel of oil and
all the good stuff goes into
pharmaceuticals it goes into plastics it
goes into other you know products all
the products that we use really are
coming out of that barrel of oil so
there's a lot of people who are working
on the classic fermentation in ethanol
butanol but using these novel organisms
you
genetically modified ecoli principally
to make a specific molecule like a
dybbuk acid that then goes into nylon
you know things like that so these
sugars are the foundation upon which all
of that being able to replace that
barrel of oil comes into and it's the
price of those sugars and the
variability in that price that really
has a big impact on the profitability of
biofuel and bio product market so that's
why we really focused there and in stock
mentioned Solazyme actually grows algae
in the dark on sugars and they produce
cosmetics from some of that and they
also produced lipids for biofuels out of
that so a lot of different ways that
these sugars can be used and what we're
trying to do is trying to build the
foundation of that pic and niche
industry to scale this process up and
then have it expand into that broader
spectrum because you can't tackle all of
those things at once now just to give
you a little bit of sense that we have
done done this in the laboratory and
worked on that we talked about the
photosynthetic conversion efficiency TDC
and TOS here total dissolved carbon or
total organic carbon so here's our
consortium growing on raw sea water
which is how we do it in the open ponds
here it is growing on a defined media in
the laboratory and here's a fresh water
sign of bacteria growing by itself on a
defined media and you can see that we
can produce a lot more total organic
carbon than the freshwater of things and
this is this is this inherent
characteristic of the marine side of
bacteria to be able to do that you can
also see the photosynthetic conversion
efficiency so this is photons and this
is the photosynthetically active photons
between 400 and 700 nanometers the ones
that the photosynthetic apparatus picks
up directly to sugars so this is not
just you know photosynthetic efficiency
to biomass but directly to the sugars
and you can see that we're significantly
higher you know our consortium and
that's really the foundation upon which
we think that this can actually begin to
you know at least make a dent in some
parts of this industry segment and then
on the bottom curve the bottom the red
the red curve here is actually showing
the girl for this of our consortium with
no added nitrate you can see that that
actually is growing faster better than
then some of the organisms growing
separately or growing a different search
on the defined medium with nitrate so we
have been able to do you know some
bootstrapping stuff in the laboratory
and need to you know get financing to
really take it to the next level talked
about the productivity just to make it
more graphical corn and sugar cane is
where the benchmarks now for bio ethanol
and they're about five tons per acre per
year we're estimating a hundred tons per
acre per year so 20 times more efficient
is is our target goal and that's what
we're aiming for we in the end the deal
we grant if we get that going that would
be our target productivity another way
to look at the productivity is to look
directly at corn and sugar cane and this
is gallons of ethanol per acre per year
so corn sugar cane miscanthus is a grass
crop that's sort of the cellulosic
conversion and that would be something
to take that take those cellulosic
sugars break them down use those to
produce ethanol now it's not a direct
comparison really because we're sugars
algae is producing biofuels but they do
conversions to look at gallons of
gasoline equivalent so this is all an
equivalent scale and you can see were
about eight times more efficient than
this campus which is something that's
attracted a lot of venture capital money
a lot of grant funding and things like
that so we're really looking at trying
to take advantage of the advantage of
our system and one of the lot of those
competitive advantages that we're not
competing for land we're not competing
for food right we're not competing you
know for land route these are you know
marginal lands these are lands near the
code you know the ocean could be desert
lands near the ocean so you're not
competing with food you're not competing
for you know land you're not using fresh
water I mean we would use some fresh
water but nothing like modern
agriculture nothing like the processing
and growth of miscanthus and nutrient
resources we're not using fertilizers
we're not using pesticides things like
that so we're really trying to develop a
very sustainable system baraka mentioned
this end cap program which is a free
program through NREL for
commercialization for small businesses
and so what they've done is looked at
the production and purification of our
sign of bacterial sugars so just
starting with that and building an Excel
model test make the key mass and energy
balances they quantify all the
associated capital equipment and
operating costs for
equipment and to operate those the farm
and in the end come up with a minimum
sugar selling price which would be the
benchmark compared to say corn and cane
or the cellulosic sources some of the
features in the model the biomass
propagation and production ponds is one
unit of the process that we would need
to do the economics involved and then
there's the separation the
centrifugation removing the biomass from
the salty sugar water and then the sugar
recovery and purification process this
is what rock was talking about with
using some sort of micro filtration or
reverse osmosis or some other technology
and again where the engineering really
needs to come in and develop and
optimize the system that's going to
allow you to economically separate those
sugars out and get those into a
fermentation process and then also
looking at the co products and waste
products and they looked at you know
what would be our waste products and
what other products coming out of the
system could actually have economic
value versus being an economic deficit
and I think in any one of these biofuel
or in this entire segment you know
trying to replace oil you really have to
you have to eat every dollar out of the
system you can you have to be as mass
and energy efficient as you can to be
able to compete with oil because you
know they have that hundred year head
start they've got you know embedded
subsidies and tax incentives and things
like that so to make this work and a lot
of work that went into our model is
based on NREL has done a lot of work
with algae and biodiesel and so they our
system is not dissimilar in that you've
got these open ponds and you've got some
of the similar you know water processing
water handling things like that it's all
a very similar kind of system and what
they've discovered is it the economics
do not work unless you can use these Co
products and develop what we call and
integrated by a refinery and that's sort
of an industry standard right now of how
people are trying to put all of this
together but it's not just one crop one
product but it really has to be this you
know Eco mimicry based concept where
you're putting all of those elements
together to make the economics work and
to make it sustainable so somebody asked
one of the questions was about you know
one of the questions that was submitted
we're about what are all the different
aspects of this process and what are the
what are the carbon costs of this and
what's the sort of the energy return on
investment so lifecycle associate some
sort of you know some people that we
know from locally put together this
greenhouse gas analysis so looking at
the greenhouse gas emissions of the
different steps of our process compared
to petroleum gasoline so chemicals and
fertilizers like I said almost nothing
we're not we're not using those at all
you know very very little bit of trace
elements that we might need to
supplement the sea water the cultivation
the pond systems you know there's some
greenhouse gas emissions associated with
pumping the fluids around the separation
desalination turns out to be a big cost
there's a lot of energy that's required
to run those processes and that's where
some significant gains could be made
both in terms of greenhouse gas emission
reductions as well as in in terms of the
economics and then the biofuel
production the fermentation systems and
things like that have to be incorporated
in if we're going to look at all the way
to gasoline and this is something that
we wouldn't have direct control over but
that would be our partners and then
biofield transport and delivery one of
the things that we've talked you know
built into our model is that we want to
be co-located with our partners you
can't can't ship seawater you know into
the middle of the country and you can't
ship dilute you know sugar solutions
around so you really want to have that
fermentation system right there there's
other advantage of that too because off
the fermentation you can take the carbon
dioxide run that back into your
propagation system so you're not wasting
the co2 coming off fermentation which
are actually using it as an input to
another part of the process and then of
course there's there's there's
greenhouse gas emissions with the actual
combustion of the ethanol so we compare
very favorably in this analysis with
gasoline it would give us an advanced
EPA biofuel rating which would get us
some of those rands and those other
credits and things like that as a
process question saying this on
greenhouse gas emissions from the energy
needed to process this what kind of
energy faces are you using because this
for like a coal based or so so these so
everything all the all this section is
for sign of bacterial sugars fermented
by yeast to ethanol and a traditional
bio
fuel fat versus petroleum gasoline vs
burning just gasoline in a car right so
you're comparing you know the ethanol
that you would use if you had a car that
was you know around a 100 car or just
using that just the energy embedded in
that ethanol how much energy went in and
how much greenhouse gases went in to
getting that same amount of fuel that
you would from a gallon gasoline that
co2 that it wouldn't it it's it's the
it's the total greenhouse gas emissions
of the whole process so if you're
pumping fluids it's the electrical
energy to pump the fluids around if
you're you know using plastic pond liner
for your propagation system it's the
embedded energy in that pond liner so
it's sort of try and capture the cradle
to grave greenhouse gas use of of our
process compared to gasoline that answer
your question oh yeah that is good where
you have your plan then the energy like
the co2 by energy then uses kinda
different so I guess I'm nothing burned
coal or update burglars and solar oh I
see in terms of where we're getting that
like limiting right yeah well that's not
that's not here this model is not at
that level in fact if you look up there
you can see it's actually energy part of
the energy is conversion is in mega
joules so it's not and it's not based
specifically on Cole's not based on or
anything like that it's it's more
generic and it's not that detail does
that make sense you know what I mean so
it will change depending where they look
at ya rabbi loads out and if for example
if you're able to use your biomass in an
anaerobic digester and generate your
electricity locally right then that's
going to have significant advantages
versus if you're using you know dirty
coal from china to to run your process
no that's a very good question and you
know we are not at that level of detail
in our in our you know this analysis
right now this was this was kind of a
free you know exchange of ideas from you
know and these models are pretty well
developed
until we would have more of a system you
know with the specific details on that
facility we wouldn't even have the
information to put into a more detailed
model so just briefly wanted to give you
an idea you know it's not just all you
know schematic diagrams you know that
this is actually you know we're actually
making real progress towards getting
this down outside so Moss Landing Marine
Lab is rocky mentioned is down near the
power plant in moss landing on your way
down to Monterey and right out here they
built a new aquaculture facility which
has access to seawater and we would you
know have couple thousand gallon tanks
that we could use to then to you know
put our construction sign of bacteria
into those tanks measure those we can
then take our we can measure our
productivity we could look at the scale
up issues how it works you know a larger
volumes and then do all of the sugar
analysis and microbiology analysis with
sra and lbl support now monterey blue
water farms actually now has leased this
facility which is next right next door
to the power plant has existing ponds
has in raceway ponds here has some
smaller ponds here we would partner with
them and be able to use those facilities
to bring in see what they have also you
know the permits and all the regulate
regulatory issues have been resolved to
get seawater into here and also to
dispose of the sea water out of there so
we could use these existing facilities
so we're actually would be able to
bootstrap ourselves pretty quickly to
going from a few thousands of gallons up
to a one acre pond and in our strategy
is to have a one acre pond as are sort
of our base unit of operations so get to
to build and operate and manage and
characterize a one acre pond system and
then much like solar panels when you
want to scale up when you need larger
volumes when you want to get to the
chevron scale ability to going to meet
that demand you like solar panels you
add more panels right you don't make
bigger and bigger ponds you just add a
modular pawn system that is well
characterized well understood because
the pond management is really important
you need to have the growth you need to
have the reliability of those systems so
our strategy is to bootstrap off of some
existing facilities and abilities down
there and then once once that's proved
out would be to attract a commercial
partner to work with us and to do an
offtake agreement and we would co-locate
with them this actions to be a pond farm
down in Baja California that we just
plucked off Google Earth
and you know you know tens and hundreds
of thousands of acres of desert that you
know could potentially be suitable to
get to the kind of scales that you'd
need to be able to produce enough you
know fuels to initially get a niche
market into the bio products market to
get into biofuels for example we scaled
it out the plaintiff in Richmond is 50
million gallons of ethanol per year is
what they're mandated by the state to
use that would be a five thousand acre
facility probably not very likely we
need a five thousand acre facility this
cost effective in Northern California
but in baja california coastal china in
the arabian peninsula north africa
places like that you would be able to
build facilities of a sufficient scale
without the land fresh water food
competition issues that would start to
be able to at least you know make one of
those stabilization wedges of addressing
climate change i don't know if that's a
concept that you've talked about in your
class but basically ideas is it's all
got to work right to really do to really
keep the oil in the ground you've got to
have solar energy that works energy
efficiency and conservation you've got
to have some biofuels you got to boil
replacements you know somebody talked
about electric cars versus versus you
know transportation fuels I think you
need all of that to work and that's you
know sort of where we're where we're
headed yeah yep so you would a place
like baja would be a pretty obviously
good location for a place like made some
place with a hard winter probably
probably not probably not yeah probably
more you know equatorial you know or
somewhere within that band and in places
and you can think of it as also
opportunities for rural economic
development you know having a facility
that is and that the last saw the last
night after this when we get up there
just really quickly rocco talked about
the desalination you know a lot of
different options we've looked at a lot
of companies that we looked at that are
putting these things together looking at
both the energy costs which you know
tends to be about six cents a pound out
of our projected maybe you know 12 to 18
cents a pound and about 4 cents a pound
for the capital cost for the equipment
so it's a big bite in the economic model
and it's it that's an area where you
know engineering and biology need to
work together to be able to solve some
of those problems and come up with with
solutions that are going
make that work eration type of work oh
yeah yeah we should talk okay yeah I
would love to you know nobody no other
options might be and last slide I know
we're probably coming up against our
time limit here but this is our concept
of the integrated coastal biorefinery
this is sort of the big eco mimicry
concept where you're bringing your
growing your sign of bacteria in these
ponds you're separating it you're taking
your salty seawater you're processing it
through some some efficient process
you're getting this this feedstock that
can go into algal growth can go directly
to bio plastics you can go into
fermentation and distillation process to
produce an ethanol chemicals and things
like that that co2 feeds back into your
pawns the nexus with the aquaculture
industry is that there's a lot of
nitrate and ammonium it comes off of
their fish farming and they before they
can dump that back in the ocean they've
got to get rid of that our sign of
bacteria could eat up that nitrogen
waste and put fresh you know clean up
that water for seawater return
amplifying the biomass and that biomass
coming from both you know all these
different sources then becomes an input
for the fish food so very nice tightly
coupled mass and energy balance system
you know if if that biomass isn't used
for fish feed it could go into anaerobic
digestion for example is one option that
we've looked at it would be able to
produce energy and you can get some some
recently good compost out of some of the
some of the wet anaerobic systems that
are you know commercially available so
looking at building you know a system
like that is is you know way beyond
anything i looked at NASA for you know
you know a Mars mission or something
like that it's really a complicated
biological ecological and engineering
problem and you know it's great to see
people interested in you know pursuing
you know trying to solve some of those
problems because a couple of couple of
microbiologists on our own we're not
going to do it by ourselves we lot
support so i'm happy to open it up for
questions and yeah how are you want to
proceed eyes are good
these fonts I do you keep them as a
batch reactor do like running constantly
it really be to have a batch operation
and we're looking at about maybe a
three-week residence time so and then
that's another reason to have a lot of
smaller ponds because I can tell you
from just doing laboratory work that you
know you can do things exactly the same
with bacterial cultures and sometimes it
just dies and it just doesn't work and
so you're going to have you know you're
going to have some subset of those ponds
that are probably going to be in the
process of being cleaned out or you know
the culture crashes or gets contaminated
so you want to have redundancy built
into the system and these batch
processes so that you're being able to
provide a constant steady supply of
sugar to your partner there who's doing
fermentation or processing to whatever
end product yeah so last summer I
peer-reviewed paper on like a study of
animal interactions with offshore ponds
essentially it was like you know a box
they left out okay and they were like
testing us to see like how seals how any
other kind of ample seagulls interact
with it um and yeah that was a pretty
boring study in my family I did didn't
go over a lot of the other possible pros
and confidence i was wondering like what
is preventing us from doing offshore
like there's just the pros and cons in
europe well i think trying to manage so
there's there's a guy actually who you
know did his work at aim so it was
talking about floating bags in the ocean
where he would put you now have these
floating bags of algae out in the ocean
and it would be thermally regulated and
you'd be able to get your son from that
and and you know it's a complicated
environment to work in it's a really
really rough rugged environment you know
I dabble a little bit surfing I can tell
you it could be really really damaging
environment so it was never a
consideration of ours to do offshore you
know aquaculture type no really very
well and and the idea you know the you
know near coastal areas i think you know
could work really well but to try to you
know grow it out in the in the ocean in
it is I just think they're really cost
competitive then they spent the Omega
project is what we call he spent 07
million dollars before they finally
realized that it just was too
impractical and not going to work and
the girl to the organisms wasn't all
that efficient either they have problems
with the bags they have problems with
with growing the organisms and
efficiently photosynthetic efficiency
and all he had organism shading each
other it was messy man there's been a
lot of research done you know for
probably about 35 years on on open ponds
outdoors one of our ideas though is that
probably to put some sort of covering
over the ponds you know like the you
know you see a lot of the greenhouses
it's just really you know PVC pipe with
with plastic cloth over to be able to
keep a lot of stuff from getting into
the pond so you don't have problems with
contamination as much you know keeping
out you know predators because you know
sugar is a real commodity out there and
there in the wild world and so anything
that gets into your paw and the DEET
setup which is why we want to keep the
residence time short so that we get in
there we find out what the optimal time
in when the sugars are their peak and
then get them out of there reset the
pond and start over and that's that's
where the real empirical work outside in
the lab needs to prove that this can
work and then I think that would where
the where the more outside an investment
would come another question like Korean
would that affect because you need that
light it wouldn't be yeah it's my screen
it is a mesh we've done this and
actually the organisms grow up quite
well because they also put a
synthetically efficient they don't need
quite as many photons there is a problem
sometimes where you can get them to be
to get too many photons and there's
photobleaching so it eliminates that the
other thing that if the covering does
not only keeps out a lot of things but
it also decreases the evaporation
evaporation tends to be a problem Oh
selectively like solar cells per I mean
is there a certain wavelength range that
the Santa bacteria uses yeah 400 to 700
and
and so with like theoretically would it
be possible to have like a selective
solar cell awfully transparent one that
is a major he showed a couple electrical
energy generation with rage sure yes
that would be a great idea if you could
have sort of a porous mesh over that it
would be the physical barrier you need
would let the right wavelengths through
and then capture the other you know
parts of Italy you know electromagnetic
spectrum and used to her electricity
that would be a great add on to that are
you guys familiar with building 239 in
essence that's where we work yeah very
familiar Y on the fourth floor I think
they were experimenting with that are
like just on the rooftop they have date
yeah and now right in front of the
building or near the parking lot they
have a solar panel that's about as big
as that wall or almost beat that wall
yeah is done oh yeah okay I'm on the
workforce okay good no that's it good
idea what you plant you in the brine
that's generated in the feedstock
production that's a really good question
if you could help us solve that that's a
very good value you know what one thing
that they've talked about down and wanna
read the aquaculture guys is that you
know is to bleed their the return water
back down in deep and slowly so that it
doesn't cause localized salination and
disruption because that's a very
sensitive marine ecosystem down there so
the the California Coastal Commission in
Monterey County the regulations are very
tight but you know yeah cumulating Brian
over time it's really a challenge but to
do that I mean some of it could go maybe
into industrial salts and things like
that but it's it's an area that we have
not put a lot of effort into yet it's
just there's a lot of moving pieces here
and but that's a good catch because you
can see that it there's no arrow coming
on exactly yes how's this different like
taking see wouldn't do 718 York instead
of just taking one more water like why
dude well so well because because the
sugar in the salt molecules are very
similar in molecular weight the size so
so that's one of the complicating
features you need to design a membrane
in a process where you get the salt and
one side and the sugar in the other side
now if we could get pure water
out of the desalination process as
another element of the integration of
that you know obviously fresh water is a
commodity and especially in desert
climates that could be a real c'mon it's
something that we've thought about but
we again we haven't you know you know we
had taken as deep a dive on that
particular question as you know we just
haven't had the capacity to look at that
but but I think if fresh water was
another product that came out of all of
this process because you're talking
about millions of gallons of seawater in
a large facility and if you could also
produce fresh water and use that for you
know local agriculture you know local
drinking water that would be good and
you would still have the salt
accumulation problem and you know that
would be you know something that yeah i
think would would need to be looked at
because I mean I know it's a problem for
you know a lot of desalination plants is
the South accumulation but then again
Cargill siendo spends all this time and
effort you know in the South Bay you
know getting the salt out of seawater
and selling it so maybe we become a
competitor with cargill for for
industrial salt this process of
separating anything like what happens to
your side after using a discarded so
this lasted biomass so ship yeah so that
could become fish food or that that
biomass could go into anaerobic
digestion there's some open questions
about the suitability of cyanobacteria
for you know the different you know
kinds of fish that they're growing but
you know out in the open ocean you know
it's a food source for a lot of things
so you know are you know assumption is
is that there's going to be a way to use
that biomass to feed the fish in this
operation if we didn't have the
aquaculture than our original plan was
to take that biomass through anaerobic
digestion and create electrical energy
and compost great thank you so much well
you're very welcome and great questions
and it's nice to be able to you know
you